[Music]
money from melanie locksmith
um i'm gonna do a video on a hyundai
which i just actually did
thought i hit the record button didn't
do it so we're gonna do it again
all right actually no we're not gonna
exit very easy we're gonna hit manual
selection okay it's a hyundai elantra
push to start okay it's america
it's a coupe it's a 2013.
it's a smart key okay now just to give
you a heads up you got to be hardline
from here
down no bluetooth on this one because
we're going to be able to pull the pin
code all right we're going to go to
control unit
now here's where you read the pin code
okay it's going to tell you also because
i just did the whole thing
and i thought i was recording and i
wasn't the function is also supported by
a 46
chip it's fine see here is where it
tells you must uh
turn off your bluetooth and be hard
lined
turn the hazards on you it tells you to
open close the door i didn't do it
it's fine it works
it takes about like two minutes maybe
that was rarely aggravated i mean i made
the whole video
we made two keys and i found out that i
didn't even hit the record button
but it is what it is i'll do a quick so
this is an important video to have
because this is the
i found out the easiest way to do it
because i was playing around with some
other system
ways to do it this seems to be the
easiest
and i got news here none of my other
machines i'll pull the pin code
you know i also have that thing that you
know i could get all the hyundai codes
that little gadget but
as far as regular machines just going in
to the obd i never seen
one pull this pin none of my machines
anyway
all right check the network
usually that's coming to the end okay
there's no slot in this car
okay there you go there's the the
passcode
let's hit okay later on it automatically
populates it which is good too
keyless system okay
immobilizer remote control learning okay
press this uh press the start button
for the ignition off it's already off
turn the hazards on we got it on already
so let's hit okay let's go to smart key
programming
this function ports everything
hit yeah all right turn the ignition off
yes okay now it just
put the pin number in there for you
automatically
okay confirm it
okay now it's going to tell us to do
when i after i hit ok
hold the remote push the button in with
the remote and
then go from there and then it'll it'll
tell you the program so hit okay
go on the button and now see what
happens now it succeeded
would i like to pro program another one
yes because we got one right here
now remember also guys if your customer
finds their keys you got to let them
know it's
not going to work
it's not gonna work see we got two now
uh it's not gonna work unless
uh they're gonna have to come back and
reprogram because it it erases
everything
all righty one second let's check the
remote
there we go let's start the car so you
can see
[Music]
and we're there it is hyundai elantra
all done take care guys
[Music]